and I look back over the last 150 years
I would say this is up there with the
three or four biggest mistakes that we
could have made as a country the two
others just to set them in the right
kind of context the two biggest mistakes
we made as a country in the in the in
the century and a half before this were
not granting self-government Ireland in
the late 19th century which was a
catastrophic mistake which we're still
recovering from today and which in our
generation and indeed in the lives of
many of those who were here today was
still was terrorism on the streets of
London I live by Regents Park every day
I passed the bandstand when I go my walk
first thing in the morning in Regent's
Park which has a plaque to the twelve
world green jackets who were who were
killed when a bomb exploded in the
middle of the afternoon concert on a
Saturday afternoon by the IRA that is a
direct consequence of us not getting
policy on Ireland right in the 19th
century and we had an opportunity under
Gladstone to create a self-governing
Ireland within the United Kingdom and if
we done it then we wouldn't have had all
these terrible consequences which
blighted so much of the 20th century we
got that wrong the other big mistake we
got wrong catastrophic mistake was going
into the First World War which everybody
thought would be one of those short wars
that will be over by Christmas and ended
up as a massive configuration which then
caused the Second World War what was
essentially a civil war in Europe for
thirty years now so let's just let me
just pause you there because you talked
about the fundamental issues but Francis
and I both voted remain on the
referendum but isn't the fundamental
issue here democracy you know I grew up
in Russia in the Soviet Union where we
didn't have it and when I see a vote
that went through I didn't vote to leave
but most people did isn't the
fundamental issue here respecting the
wishes of the people even if as you say
and I may take I may not heed some
people think that it will be damaging to
their constituents but have we not had a
parliament that actually doesn't
represent the wishes of the people well
the people can't betrayed the people
that is a fundamental principle of
democracy and democracy is not about one
vote at one moment and then no votes
ever again that that is generally
speaking however I'm not saying I'm
opposed to the second one what I'm
saying is we're going to implement the
results of the first no but that is the
answer to your point the answer to your
point is this whole business
grexit is itself for process when we had
the referendum three and a half years
ago people couldn't know what brexit
would mean not because they were stupid
or because they'd informed but because
there was no proposal on the table the
only proposal for Breck's it's on the
table three and a half years ago was
forwards on the ballot paper leave the
European Union there was no plan behind
it there was no agreement even amongst
the people in favor of a brexit as
thought it should mean some that was
compatible with staying in the single
market and the customs union including
the prime minister at the moment who
said so in the referendum campaign other
people said that we should leave some
people said that we would maintain
freedom of movement which is fundamental
to the whole concept of the European
Union whether people can travel freely
across borders or not other people said
that we couldn't as that has come to be
worked through and as it has remained
deeply controversial within our
democracy the right thing to do was as I
still believe we will will to hold a
further referendum shouldn'ta questions
on that then be given that we voted to
leave either we leave on the withdrawal
agreement of Boris Johnson's negotiated
or we leave with no deal and those
should be the job but obviously not
because the the majority of people
according to opinion surveys and
majority of MPs are actually in favor of
staying in the European Union but we had
over surrender already but again we
couldn't judge staying in the European
Union against a specific deal where's
this time we can and the right thing to
do I mean what why would you want to
constrain the options you're putting to
people when there's by far the most
popular option out there is one that's
absolutely credible which is staying in
the European Union so I completely agree
with you
this is a fundamental democratic
principle the fundamental difference
between the European Union and the
Soviet Union which you referred to is
one is a democracy and one is not you
know when he'll always forget all these
phone secretary they come and go so fast
it was one called Huntz wasn't there
recently he's now so receded into the
distance when he in trying to curry
favor a Conservative Party conference
likened to the European Union to the
Soviet Union Donald Tusk
the president of the European Union who
was a solidarity activists in the
nineteen eighties against the Soviet
Union made the fundamental point that
there is a difference in an empire and a
democracy and it's because the European
Union is a democracy that it's proved to
be it's a club of democracies it's 28
democracies it's a club
it's because it's proved to be so viable
and so successful that that we should be
staying in it and not leaving it
[Music]